sachez que la nouvelle née mesure 8 cm
qu'elle est faite de 10 espèces
différentes de tabac brun qui provient
exclusivement des plantations
métropolitaine elle est donc bien de
chez nous une cigarette bien de chez
nous un tabac cultivé en france pendant
les trente glorieuses
les français ont la clope tricolore au
bec il fume le tabac brun ou noir des
gauloises et autres gitane ce tabac il
vient d'un peu partout dans l'hexagone
mais surtout du sud ouest et c'est alors
une filière prospère leurs récoltes et
écoulé à coup sûr puisque la loi
garantit sa vente
d'autre part des systèmes spéciaux
d'assurance garantissent les planteurs
de tabac une production de tabac
entièrement sous la coupe de la seita
une entreprise publique qui détient
alors le monopole de la culture de la
fabrication et de la distribution du
tabac en 1976 la production française de
tabac atteint un sommet la seita vit son
âge d'or 85 mille tonnes de produits
manufacturés plus de 10 fois le total
des importations
il possède 28 usines et emploie onze
mille personnes
pas question de mettre en péril une
telle entreprise le père il arrive
pourtant très vite
lorsqu'une loi votée en cette même année
1976 limite le monopole de la seita
dorénavant les marques étrangères
peuvent abreuver le marché hexagonal de
cigarettes blondes de plus en plus
appréciée des français
six ans plus tard les effets négatifs
sur la production se font sentir
l'évolution du goût des fumeurs vers les
tabac blond explique sans doute les
difficultés d'état doit français car le
nombre de fumeurs lui n'a pas dit mieux
le secteur serions alors dans les années
80 dans la culture du tabac blond mais
c'est trop tard les français ont eu le
temps de s'attacher aux marques
étrangères
et ce n'est pas tout la concurrence
internationale les délocalisations
d'usinés de la seita et les politiques
publiques anti tabac pèse sur la
production tabacoles françaises qui
chute de 63% entre 1976 et 1996 en 1995
la seita est privatisée conséquence les
prix du tabac ne sont plus garantis pour
beaucoup de tabaculteurs une page se
tourne
lors de la privatisation
le la nouvelle société risk
s'approvisionner avec des tabacs
français mais au cours mondial dix ans
ce sera des prix tout à fait différent
et on peut voir la paire de trois ou
quatre ans du kilo ce qui mettrait en
qui compromettrait beaucoup la
production du tabac en france
la superficie de la culture du tabac en
france a été divisé par 10 depuis le
début des années 1950
aujourd'hui avec le tarissement des
subventions le tabac est devenue une
culture de niche
[Musique]